ladies and gentlemen of the reject
Nation
I'm only here to introduce this video to
tell you
that everything you're about to hear is
so stupid this is all
this is all true I can't believe it
get away Corey
as some of you may know I host a
show a corner if you will of this very
Network called koi's Comic Corner as
others of you may know I uh discuss
comic books for a living and comic book
movies and as you're all about to find
out I've never seen Superman the movie
in my life I made a list of the top 25
comic films of all time and upon
reviewing the comments went I just
didn't think Superman was that great and
then went
I don't think I've seen Superman and
then Greg and I started talking and he
asked me what the plot of Superman was
and I didn't know I've never seen
Superman the movie so you dear citizens
of the reject Nation are ready to join
me as I find out can a man fly will I
believe it hit the like hit or hit a
comment below yell at me it's inevitable
let's see where this ranks in my movie
comic experience having never seen it
and if you'd like to do a full feature
length sync it up with me watch it
alongside check out the patreon this
whole thing's gonna be there and this
movie is very short and this is the very
last thing I'm doing this leads right up
to my birthday this is how I'm ending my
my year let's find out Christopher Reeve
I hear he's pretty good
[Music]
and at times of fear and confusion the
job of informing the public is the
responsibility of the Daily Planet a
great Metropolitan newspaper whose
reputation for clarity and Truth great
intro I like that this feels historic
and I imagine even felt historic then
like it feels Timeless and and important
[Music]
that was cool
foreign
man I love Miniatures that's pretty
these
are matters of undeniable fact
take down to bring in their presence the
vote must be unanimous to her
you alone will condemn us if you wish
and you alone will be held responsible
by me
you will about all before material I
swear it both you and then one day your
ass
this is so extreme in its composition
the Sci-Fi elements are a lot and then
the visual composition they don't make a
lot of movies of this scope
with that cinematography tell you that
we must evacuate this plan immediately
if not sooner the decision of the
council is final
I like the different family crests
it feels lived in feels like there is
history in them but why Earth during
their Primitives thousands of years
behind us
virtually invulnerable
great exposition
why would we include a piece of
kryptonite
that was a great opening performance I
mean it's Marlon Brando
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
way to show a planet ending as opposed
to just blindly exploding especially
with what we know the infrastructure of
uh The Fortress of Solitude and some of
the comic imagery of Krypton this is a
really cool way to show
the end of Krypton
all right
this must have been surreal to see in a
theater
in the 70s
that was beautiful
[Music]
what was that
man pot Kent
[Music]
vibing we could say he's a child of my
cousin in North Dakota
and just now often now you saw how we
found it
that's that's so clever I like that
nicely done
that's interesting because this so works
for the time but I wonder how like I
feel like American audiences now are so
cynical I don't know how this would
translate maybe that's why they're
having a hard time I love the hope and
the The Whimsy the the earnestness
um maybe a period piece
for Superman hey Clark I'm ready for
tomorrow's games okay Mount Vernon High
Lana oh good it is Lana before Lois I
was curious if which storyline
a whole bunch of us are going up to Mary
Ellen's would you like to come sure
sounds like it'd be a lot of fun I got a
lot of work to do what are you talking
about I just finished stacking off
all that oh clean this up Clark
oh it's getting bullied Clark Kent
[Music]
cheesy but cute
look there's Clark
that's clever there's one thing I do
know son and that is you are here for a
reason it's not to score touchdowns
good Puck can't wisdom
this uh so far has done an incredible
job at the exposition uh and tear those
guys apart is I'm pretty sure straight
from the comic or a comic at least it's
got
such honest sensibilities
um which again it's interesting if this
would work today oh no
oh no
oh
that's heartbreaking it's just gonna
happen like that
oh the heart attack
[Music]
I knew it had to happen some way and
well that worked for me better than a
tornado did oh what a way to go though
good life lesson
pass away quick proud of you kid
[Music]
ding that hurt
hmm why doesn't that hurt him
do you
know where you're headed
always remember
so far it's very sweet movie
very sweet
as it should be
what's the first fight gonna be I sense
a fight coming
polar bear
Sea Beast
I mean he went North
strange way to get the Metropolis oh of
course the Fortress of Solitude I
assumed using a lot of metropolis I
don't know why this makes way more sense
who are you as a man
[Music]
I assumed it'd be Christopher Reeves all
the time
[Music]
is this Christopher Eve is it already
Christopher Reeves is that Christopher
Reeves is there an age Gap like is there
a time Jump
what's happened
[Music]
fascinated by the relationship with
Kryptonite seems to be some sort of
activator in this case
which makes some sense if it also hurt
him
does not seem to hurt him
[Music]
it's like those little geodes you can
grow in a lab
I'm your father
[Music]
the old years
interesting if they're just spelling it
out
who am I
the name is Khalil
you are the only survivor of the Planet
Krypton
even though you've been raised as a
human being you are not one of them that
is a cool shot man come with me now my
son as we break through the ball of your
Earthly confinement traveling through
time space
in Far exceed those Immortal it has
forbidden for you to interfere with
human history
very trippy I like how disorientingly
psychedelic it is at times for this
reason above all their capacity for good
I have sent them you
[Music]
that was cool I like that
[Music]
yeah
yeah oh that's awesome okay that was rad
I like it
[Music]
loved that that was such a great way to
come back to do some time playing
to evolve him
take note modern movies that was awesome
how many teasing bloodletting two
yeah what a great Jimmy Olsen how do you
spell Massacre uh m-a-s- in the comic
book she historically has a grammatical
and spelling errors even as one of the
greatest Pulitzer prize-winning uh
journalists of all time low
Christopher Reeve it wasn't the same guy
uh they aged him up changed the cast
forgot what he looked like I apologize
uh Lois why don't you take Kent out to
uh meet everybody after just introduce
him around great uh body language I know
I've seen the GIF of him like turning
into Superman but it's really impressive
to see in the minutia of uh of the
office that's cool I was wondering if
um perhaps you could arrange for half my
salary to be sent to this address on a
weekly basis he sends a check every week
to his sweet gray-haired old mother
actually she's silver-haired
there are very few people left in the
world who feel comfortable saying that
word what word as well I thought it was
kind of natural
sorry
I love how clumsy he is to
throw people off it is so good he's
incredible as Clark I am
I get it I get it
please don't point that at me sir
sorry now come on lady hand it over
[Music]
what are you doing
[Music]
what happened you fainted sorry
he's exceptional
make it track 22. I seen him and I'm
right on them lower level track 22.
[Music]
what a great stooge well-cast little
henchman
[Music]
[Music]
that baritone of
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
First Act of Lex Luthor killing a cap
sick
Gene hack but not shave his head for Lex
Luthor
is that explained maybe that's explained
how many girls do you know who have a
Park Avenue address like this one 200
feet below do you realize what people
are shelling out up there for a few
miserable rooms off a common elevator
what more could anyone ask
Ed
[Music]
Superman's gonna have to save Lois
[Music]
it's not good
[Music]
that's cool like practical like they
messed [ __ ] up
all right
[Music]
I would get away from there Pope go go
[Music]
Jurassic Park I see where you got some
of this sequencing from
[Applause]
oh it's just a half
that's good
[Music]
you've got me who's got you
that's where that line came from
I know it from Jay and Silent Bob
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
the opposite of uh the Captain America
curl is the straight arm
I guess that would be
deltoid some lats extension
statistically speaking of course it's
still the safest way to travel he's so
good at Superman who are you
a friend
bye
[Music]
all right I believe a man can fly
that's freaking cool especially in 78
this must have blown mines
come on Tom
Tom Cruise doing the work oh that's a
cool shot
yes the booty yeah I get the uh the
Clark Kent Superman Duality hype this is
impressive
[Music]
that show is great too take him away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these five minutes of super Manning are
better than a lot of the Superman stuff
I've seen foreign
[Music]
it's not mad he's disappointed
[Music]
gotta save a kitten what Superman
without saving a kitten here you go Miss
thanks Mister
[Music]
bye frisky
long now
bye he's so polite saying eyes and buys
a lot of greetings in the Superman man
can this work today
buildings they hire by in regular life
Roger
well
doesn't look too good what do you think
what the hell what happened not good oh
we lost the whole engine precious yeah
and Superman just said statistically the
safest we got two accidents of
metropolis are nearby come on one human
error one nature it's not safe to fly
near Metropolis
[Music]
a lot of the Superman Returns um imagery
plays a lot better having seen the
original
because if any human being we're going
to perpetrates with a fantastic hoax it
would have been me
okay good Flex isn't bold
I got concerns I want
the inside dope on this guy
has he got a family what is the yes
he's gonna wind up with the single most
important interview since solid casting
God talked to Moses
especially without again there's no
precedent of of superhero movies or
comic book movies and it isn't too hokey
it's just really sincere
and and it's good it's a good movie
sorry to uh drop in and you like this
Miss Lane but I've been thinking you
know there must be a lot of questions
about me that people in the world like
to know of course yes uh
you really shouldn't smoke in on this
Lane
don't tell me lung cancer right
I mean yeah not yet thank goodness
hahaha
do you have a girlfriend
uh no I don't but uh if I did Miss Lane
you'd be the first to know about it
is it true that you can see through
anything oh yes it can
color underwear am I wearing this would
have a problem with seeing through lead
oh that's interesting
cute this is all very cute
come from a planet called Krypton with a
sea
no actually actually it's Krypton with a
k-r-ypt
you like pink
[Laughter]
very much
why are you here there must be a reason
for you to be here yes I'm here to fight
for truth and Justice in the American
way
we're gonna end up fighting every
elected official in this
ride with me you mean I can fly yeah
actually uh I'd be handling the flying
if that's okay I need a sweater you must
be kind of it's not going to be warm
enough
they're very cute good chemistry
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's funny because this feels
not quite like Peter Pan but the the
flight style this does remind me of
Peter Pan and windy yellow
yeah this is very cute physics don't
make a lot of sense but it's very cute
if you need a friend
I'm the one to fly to
[Music]
you need to be loved
here I am see that's how you fly with
Superman it's not like a weird touch
thing where it gives you Powers that's
that makes more sense good night
oh good night
Superman
she said the thing
um Lois we did have a date tonight
remember
Lois
you haven't been uh
I better get a code
no I mean
that's the moment I've seen that's
really special
that's some Alexander technique that is
that was beautiful
but we've got to go back to being Clark
[Applause]
practical stunts for life
odd look at this dispatch
people break into a museum in the dead
of night killed two people and what do
they take a worthless piece of meteorite
how do you figure that that was found
inexplicably from looking at an
encyclopedia
I was a reporter before most of my
friends were copy boys
[Music]
out his clothes just changed that
doesn't make what
what that's not a power
that doesn't make any sense it occurs to
me that a 500 Megaton bomb planted at
just a proper point would would destroy
most of California hello New West Coast
my West Coast
Marina Deluxe
[Music]
millions of people's lives don't matter
but uh well they do but they really do
because so does Lois Lane's life on the
fault line it's Kryptonite Superman
little souvenir from the old hometown
we all have our little faults mine's in
California
clever
good use of pun
faulty word play
Lex my mother lives in Hackensack
dark
if I help you to prompts to save my
mother first I promise I promise
[Music]
top gun Maverick
I did not expect it to actually detonate
oh he's gonna go back in time
he's got a uh because they're not
supposed to meddle uh human history but
I imagine
he'll rationalize it
happy birthday
this is pretty rad like scope for the
third Act
[Applause]
that's impressive special effects
come on Superman put them all back
together Amazing Spider-Man 33 cover but
with Superman lifting the entire San
Andreas Fault
and still saving the children
okay kids all right now
hey it's Superman
gotta keep diving in holes Superman I
guess must be another movie where you
guys are back in time
[Music]
get out of there Jimmy
[Music]
a noble tradition begins
oh no we're into a single
[Music]
that is terrifying cool practical
effects to have that
[Music]
the claustrophobia is real
nope nope
don't like that
oh those are little Miniatures look at
them I can only tell because it's in
like 4K but that was a really cool use
of practical into managers
[Music]
it is so dark that he's helping this
saving people but drowning Lois
in rocks
[Music]
man the tension I know she's gonna be
fine but man it's great great work
[Music]
no way do they kill Lois in the first
movie and then he flies back in time is
that what's happening do they kill Lois
Lane in that horrific terrifying
claustrophobia inducing buried alive way
foreign
[Music]
gotta stand against his father's wishes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
he may be fast enough to reverse time
but he's not fast enough to fight fast
enough over
those mountain ridges to save her
simultaneously
while she's
you know
being buried alive
that's so cool
look at those effects I love reverse
photography like that
come on Superman
so he's already stopping us a one at
this point there he is
can't believe they killed Lois movie one
Superman cares about everybody Jimmy
but who knows someday you know if he's
lucky
[Music]
just flies him into prison
so they never showed Gene Hackman
actually bald they just imply he's
always wearing wigs oh I was Luther
they saved it for the last appearance
I believe a man can fly I like that
look at that Alex Ross painting come to
life well this proceeded Alex Ross's
paintings but look at that
that reminded me a lot of Superman blue
which came out much later uh that
reminded me a lot of All-Star Superman
also came out much later it was my two
reading recommendations for y'all
All-Star Superman and uh Superman blue I
really enjoyed that I can't believe I'd
never seen it I think I'd maybe seen I
don't know obviously the gifts uh and
and maybe five minutes on like TNT
growing up but I didn't remember the
plot I'd obviously seen the you know the
reversing of the planet in pop culture
but I kept doubting myself as to when it
was
uh so I liked it a lot it will likely
rank in my 26 to 50 which we're going to
convince Greg to let me do
um it's probably in the top 20 of
superhero movies but I would not put in
my top 10 uh there's probably like 250
comic movies so top 20 would be that 26
to 50.
um I I see why it's beloved I definitely
like have so much reverence for it it
influenced so many things uh it did
drive me crazy and this is a problem I
have a lot of movies
um when there's two movies uh that don't
feel like they're one movie I love when
movies feel like you know disparate
movies that all come together at the end
but at no point did it feel like Gene
Hackman's Lex Luthor was in the same
movie as Christopher Reeves Superman uh
I really enjoyed the Christopher of
Superman movie and I really enjoyed his
relationship with Lois I really enjoyed
the magic and and earnesty and sheer
honesty and almost this golly gee Shucks
uh Whimsy of the Superman movie but the
reason that worked is because it was
Earnest in its honesty and I feel like
the Gene Hackman Lex Luthor was a
satirical play on 50s
um editorial comic books it felt like it
was making a commentary on the golden
age uh comic book uh Sunday newspaper
era and so it felt like there was there
was two different performances happening
and the one I enjoyed fit with Marlon
Brando fit with the backstory fit with
all these things but whenever they cut
the likes it didn't feel like the same
movie and even the scenes with Superman
and Lex felt a little disjointed so
um everything with Superman I really
loved uh I would probably give and like
that's it with the times and everything
else the special effects really special
loved the use of Miniatures loved how
tangible it felt loved the scope loved
the uh Power of the score love the the
feel of the movie they don't make movies
like this where you feel so much and I
think the reason it's so hard to make a
Superman movie is because you need that
golly gee man this guy's a Boy Scout man
I believe in him the physicality between
Clark Kent and Superman was so special
I'm really excited to see that dick
Donner cut a Superman too to be honest
now that I've seen this uh this probably
lands like a four stars for me
um this is like a B plus a minus this
will likely Fall in that 26 to 50 of of
superhero movies need to look at the
rest of my rankings I'm gonna continue
that ranking to build it out because I
want to know where this lands but I'm
really glad to have seen it I definitely
have not seen this one which means I
definitely haven't seen Superman two
three or four uh I'm gonna go B plus a
minus I'm gonna go four stars really
really special film I see why it's
revered I cannot imagine watching it
then I can't like I got so many moments
of of whoa and wonder and and Power in
2022 I cannot imagine seeing this 35
years ago 34 for the new math Wizards 34
years ago uh just what this must have
been so incredible film I see why it's a
lot of people's top ten I see why
everyone yelled at me in the chat I
deserve to get those comments but now
I've seen it and uh four stars really
really spectacular experience things
that really worked were Margot Kidder
and Christopher Lee the things that
worked Margo Kidder and Christopher
Lee's relationship I thought was really
special uh Jimmy Olsen though a small
part was very very integral to both
building the world and establishing how
people would perceive Superman from that
like eye line uh Perry White and The
Daily Planet everything with the Daily
Planet really worked
um I was really impressed at the Clark
Kent Duality I kept thinking how
impressive that was uh we're now in the
closing credits
and Marlon Brando and Gene Hackman are
both billed of Chris free that is
fascinating also I kept seeing someone
walk around the mustache that I felt
like
must be someone that would end up later
and it looks just like um
Kiefer Sutherlands now Donald Sutherland
I don't think Donald Sutherland was in
this but I kept seeing an almost Donald
Sutherland walking around the streets of
metropolis like twice he popped up I
haven't pointed out
um yeah I I was just so so impressed
with the world built
um I was so impressed with what it was
able to do with Exposition it unloaded
so much Exposition on you it gave you
Marlon Brando Exposition it gave you
lots and lots of Fairly hokey uh Lex
Luthor Exposition it gave you lots of
where Superman came from and what his
powers are
um didn't love the
sometimes powers are convenient like the
speed thing is obviously hard to clock
but it did bother me that he couldn't
get to her in time but could turn the
plan I get it is you know dramatic uh
and I get that's necessary for the
storytelling but I wish there was
something else that impeded him maybe
um Kryptonite poisoning uh something
slowed him down he had to shake it I
don't know I don't know
um I'm not writing Superman 1978 over uh
and another another slight qualm
um was the weird power to change clothes
in the sky uh one of the special things
of Superman is those grounded moments
like the photo booth and things so that
that was odd uh I couldn't tell if he
could read minds at one point
um it was like she was thinking and
wondering if she if he was reading her
mind sometimes his body language seemed
to imply that he could read her mind I
could not quite tell what was happening
there
um but those are all minor qualms like
that's me looking for things uh to be
bothered by or to you know feel about it
um
I don't know if I'd seen it
um at any different point in my life
that would change I was really trying
consciously to look at this objectively
regardless of seeing in 2022 versus
seeing it as a child uh I think I
definitely would have loved it as much
as I loved it now as a kid uh I think I
would have gotten the same sense of
wonder uh it definitely endears me to
dick down or even more Richard Donner's
always been one of my favorite directors
the Lethal Weapon franchise is one of my
all-time favorite franchises ever
um dick Downer and Schumacher were
really good friends and those are two of
my favorite directors and they uh you
know uh calibrated they uh they
coordinated a lot they collaborated
that's what I was looking for it's late
they collaborated a lot and this
reminded me of how special of a
filmmaker because it's hard you don't
often get to see new works of old works
of your favorite filmmaker so it was
really special to see uh Richard Donner
film I hadn't seen before especially one
as iconic as this uh and it lived up to
the very lofty expectations of what
Superman the movie had to be to have all
that reference I don't know why they
saved bald's gym the very end I wonder
if I was like scheduling stuff but uh
yeah got a whole lot out of it really
really I'm glad to have seen it really
curious about the second one really
curious where it falls off apparently
with the third and fourth uh I haven't
seen Superman Returns the Brandon Routh
Superman since theaters so I think the
last time I saw that would have been
0607 whenever that came out
um so that's 15 years ago at this point
so it'd be really cool to watch Superman
2 probably the dick Donner cut and then
watch Superman Returns as sort of a
Trilogy so that's what I might do with
uh with this series so if you want to
see that leave a comment below if you
enjoyed this if you've got any notes as
to why the bald cap or uh the power
adjustments and those things that I had
tiny qualms with please do let me know
uh and let me know what you think of
this this re-watch of a movie 34 years
ago is cool to do something so classic
and so different that I just somehow
didn't see in my 33 years I'm turning 34
at midnight in a few minutes and that
was a 34 year old movie feels like fate
don't it uh all right that is gonna do
what you love please I appreciate y'all
very very much please do leave a like
leave a comment subscribe to this very
Channel if you want to see me more uh on
these giant rewatches of Full Features
let me know if you want me to watch
Superman 2 let me know if you think I
should do Superman one and Superman 2
and then Batman Batman return Superman
Returns let me know let Greg know you
want me to do 26 through 50 so I can
rank this here film somewhere in there I
do think it's going to fall in that 26
to 50 range
um there's a lot of
four star uh comic book films for me and
uh this is definitely in there this is
gonna be up there but you know in that
top top 20 of all of them uh all right
like I said that's gonna do it your
lovelies have a great night we'll see
you hopefully for Superman too comment
foreign
[Music]